in 2016 you the American people you made
history you elected as president a
fighter a dealmaker a disrupter you sent
a leader to the White House who was
clearly unafraid to dismantle the status
quo in Washington DC the swamp the sewer
and also somebody that is now in two
years we see he fights to keep his
promises and get things done that he
said he'd get done frankly come hell or
high water tonight what you're
witnessing is Donald Trump doing
whatever it takes to fulfill his
promises more importantly this is about
protecting the lives of the American
people and securing the country on our
borders many lawmakers especially
Democrats ignored the crisis at our
southern border they said it's
manufactured one month ago speaker
Pelosi vowed that Congress wouldn't
spend more than a dollar on any border
wall it was immoral as it turns out
she's a little off take a look I went
through Congress I made a deal I got
almost 1.4 billion dollars when I wasn't
supposed to get one dollar not one
dollar he's not gonna get one dollar
well I got 1.4 billion but I'm not happy
with it nor am i but the president's
right he got one point three seven five
billion dollars for the wall and a bill
that tripled the funding for barriers on
the southern border over the previous
budget and it's only seven months this
budget it killed so called poison pills
like any amnesty it's not in the bill
for illegals no pathway to citizenship
no limit on ice' detentions in fact
instead of a limit this bill funds 5,000
more beds for illegal immigrant
detention and remember all the far left
radical socialist Democrats calling for
ice to be abolished well this bill
actually includes a historic funding
increase for ice including money for an
additional 600 highly needed
professional officers now still you
heard the president he's not happy nor
should anybody be happy because one
point three seven five billion for a
wall is not enough and it's why I have
called this bill garbage from the very
beginning and it's why the president is
now officially as of today declaring the
national emergency that he's been
telegraphing to
world he's going to do take a look so
I'm gonna be signing a national
emergency and what we won't really want
to do is simple it's not like it's
complicated it's very simple we want to
stop drugs from coming into our country
we want to stop criminals and gangs from
coming into our country it's an invasion
we have an invasion of drugs and
criminals coming into our country that
we stop but it's very hard to stop with
a wall it would be very easy so I think
that we will be very successful in court
I believe that as well now let's break
down exactly what this means and why
this plan will ultimately be very
successful as the president declares its
national emergency the administration
will gain access to roughly eight
billion dollars president will be able
to use the one point three seven five
billion from the budget compromise so
progress continues straight through the
rest of the fiscal year which is till
October six hundred million from the
Treasury Department's drug forfeiture
fund 2.5 billion from the dependent
Department of Defense's drug
interdiction program an additional 3.6
billion from the Department of Defense's
military construction account and he
knows the Democrats as we predicted they
got to go judge shopping they're gonna
challenge this constitutional executive
action in court but their efforts
ultimately they won't come up short one
constitutional scholar after another
agrees with us the president is standing
on firm legal ground let's look at us
code Oh law passed by Congress signed
into law and act explicitly states quote
construction of roads and fences oh that
would be a barrier a wall an
installation of lighting to block drug
smuggling corridors across international
boundaries of the United States well the
president also has standing based on US
code right there you can see it 2808
that allows construction projects for
national security and that's not even
all since 1978 a whopping 58 nays have
been declared by various presidents
starting with Jimmy Carter and guess
what 31 of those
national emergency declarations are
still in effect today former President
Obama he declared 10 national
emergencies including one that countered
the rise in crime from a deadly Mexican
cartel simply put there is major legal
legislative and constitutional
precedents for this national emergency
when it comes to stopping drugs gangs
cartels trafficking and everything else
and all the security risks to Americans
at the border as a result of an open
border
remember 300 Americans are dying weekly
from heroin 90% of which is trafficked
across our southern border in 2017
more than 70,000 Americans died from
drug overdoses excuse me is that a
manufactured crisis last year fentanyl
trafficking across the southern border
shot up a whopping hundred and
twenty-two percent in Arizona alone
fentanyl deaths have tripled since 2015
and sadly drug carnage was one part of
the crisis in just the past two years
four thousand criminal aliens were
arrested for homicide 30 thousand for
sex crimes a hundred thousand for
violent assaults that's a two year
period last year alone
eight hundred gang members apprehended
at the border a 50 percent increase from
2017 and today the President had a very
powerful message to one well fake news
hack who tried to claim that this is all
just a manufactured crisis same talking
point the media uses as their best
friends of the Democratic Party
take a look what do you say to your
critics who say that you are creating a
national emergency that you're
concocting a national emergency here in
order to get your wall because you can
get away what do you think you think I'm
creating something ask these incredible
women who lost their daughters and their
sons okay because your question is a
very political question because you have
an agenda
your CNN your fake news ouch maybe Jim
gonna walk over maybe maybe talk to the
angel moms and dads that we have on this
show made
look really weak bad pathetic heartless
and looks like when he's forced to face
brave angel moms and dads who've lived
through hell pain and suffering that
none of us can imagine you didn't want
to talk to them now tonight no matter
what you hear from Democrats or the hate
trump media the wall is getting built
the president the fighter the disrupter
the dealmaker tenacious unrelenting is
keeping his promises but also he's
winning and he's sick of winning yet the
American people of the real winners here
this is a huge win not forget the
president put him aside for a minute
doesn't win for the country this is a
win for you and your families and our
safety in our security which brings us
tonight to our Hannity watch on what is
the abusively biased hate Trump media
now recently the media's echo chamber
they've been spreading some pretty
unbelievable fake news about the
president and me and our relationship
why they're obsessed with this I don't
know take a look this is a president who
is terrified of angering his base and I
think he is concerned I could imagine
him being on the phone with Lou Dobbs
no Sean Hannity and tell him okay I have
to do this it because he's afraid of
losing this news cycle to hacks like
Sean Hannity and Lou Dobbs and Ann
Coulter he has set a precedent that will
haunt the Republican Party for decades
if not for generations 2014 Mike Pence
and 2014 Republicans battled then
President Obama in public and in court
over similar actions but 2019 Mike Pence
in many 2019 Republicans are already
saying thank you Sean Hannity may I have
another all right let me just say up
front the president nor anybody in the
White House ever called to calm me down
whatever that means and also say this
with all due respect to all of you guys
over there it's really cracking me up
here I'm thrilled with it because I've
been calling for secure borders and
build the wall first for a long time by
the way for all of you geniuses that are
overpaid in the hate Trump media and
kind of lazy let me explain what I do
for a living I am a talk show host in
other words I'm a member of the press
we're like the whole newspaper on this
show I can produce
hours and hours of radio and television
where I do straight news we do tons of
investigative reporting you're too lazy
to do or to bias to do remember we were
the only show one of the only shows that
vetted Obama Frank Marshall Davis and
acorn in Olinsky and oh yeah let's not
forget the Church of Gd America Black
Liberation Theology remember our
coverage of Bill Ayers and Bernardine
Dohrn remember all of that we also had
some serious investigations on this
program into the Duke Lacrosse scandal I
actually met with some of the kids and
the families Baltimore Maryland we were
right you all in the media were wrong
UVA Richard Jewell the scourge of gang
violence in Chicago we put up the names
on the show the man-made drought delta
smelt in california we investigated what
your kids are up to in Spring Break yeah
we do investigative reporting we do
straight news as a talk show host and
also we also did our two year
investigation into the deep state and we
have the evidence that you never paid
attention to about what was an attempted
coup on the president of United States
where they let one candidate free in an
effort to sabotage the other and of
course like every newspaper yeah we also
I said we're like the fullness we give
opinion I don't hide that I am a
registered conservative we even do
gossip occasionally in sports
two nights ago we had on Tim Tebow you
see our First Amendment freedom of the
press well part of the Free Press you
can be a talk show host and do all of
those things it covers many different
and unique roles for the press in doing
so like others so-called journalists I
use sources all the time I work the
phones daily to get information to do
reporting investigation so I can give my
audience the best information that you
guys aren't giving them and I'll never
ever by the way for all you that
speculate
I will never confirm not even deny who
my sources are who I talk to who I don't
talk to or even if I talk to people
alone what you have in the media right
now is obsession they got blinders on
and they've got this prison which they
see Donald Trump lazy overpaid people in
the hate Trump media so blind
by their hatred and rage for Donald
Trump they need to get their own sources
of information instead of falsely
speculating about mine now here's a
simple truth nobody in the media has
ever ever come close to describing the
relationship that I had with the
president that goes back well over two
decades and by the way if one that
exists I wouldn't tell you anyway all
right now to end all fake news reports
on how I accurately predicted exactly
what the president would do on the
border he didn't tell me it's simple I
paid attention to all his public
comments he said it over and over and
over again I heard him you refused to
hear him remember when he said I will
add whatever I have to add what do you
think he meant
remember when he actually said many
times I'm looking at the national
emergency seriously
he kept saying these things repeatedly
and what those of you in the fake news
industry don't seem to understand the
president does listen to other points of
view yeah but at the end of the day is
pretty amazing all of you can't figure
out that he makes up his own mind and
it's not hard to understand what he's
going to do because what he has been
doing for the last two years what he's
been saying over the last week is
usually what he ends up doing now by the
way for the record I'll say this in all
honesty if the president listened to me
he would have stopped tweeting back in
2016 or at least tweeted less because me
and a bunch of other people told him ah
you got to stop I got to admit in
retrospect I actually think he was right
to keep doing this maybe 5% less because
what he's doing is bypassing the abuse
of press that has offered people that
hate him every day and he's getting his
message directly to the American people
which as you can see an immediate
landscape full of conspiracy theories
hatred fake news is now more important
than ever before take for example this
report from News Buster's look at this
all the big three networks ABC NBC C
yes they went wild with their hysteria
collusion coverage one story that turns
out to be false after another they
dedicated over 2200 minutes of airtime
just the three networks they aired and
found zero seconds minutes for available
air time when the bipartisan Senate
report that found no collusion of evide
this week they didn't cover it at all
because then they'd have to admit they
were wrong and I happen to like the
fighter that is in the White House I do
like the man who fights tenacious
unrelenting and fights to keep his
campaign promises it's refreshing it's
energizing to watch him go down the list
and see all the success for the
Forgotten men and women that voted for
him in 2016 the policies he advocated
for in his campaign and he's now
delivering on all to be very honest I
have been supporting these are things I
publicly stated support for most of them
for 30 years on radio 23 years right
here on the Fox News Channel
why because conservatism works it's
works every time it's applied just like
I predicted Obama would fail Oh 13
million more Americans on food stamps 8
million more in poverty look at the
president's positive record-breaking
results on the economy alone new trade
policies would make it more money more
opportunities for Americans 600,000
manufacturing jobs 5.3 million new jobs
yeah I like those policies and it's
worth fighting for those policies
all right well more on this later but
first we do have to turn to our Hannity
watch on the deep state in light of
yesterday's big news huge bombshell
revelation surrounding disgrace fired
FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe now
last night we laid out the entire case
2016 small group high-ranking unelected
unaccountable bureaucrats they abuse
their power in such a way to try to rig
the 2016 election in favor of one
candidate Hillary Clinton over another
candidate Donald Trump they allowed
their chosen candidate Hillary Clinton
to stay in the race by clearing her of
all charges before they even
investigated it well things that no
other American could ever get away with
trust me do I've subpoenaed emails you
better not delete them you better not
acid wash your hard drive and bust up
your devices now in July of 2016
call me struck Oh struck interviewed
Hillary he's the guy that said we're
smelly Walmart Motors he's the guy that
said Hillary should win a hundred
million a zero anyway comeon struck and
others they decided to give her a pass
the fix was in and they didn't prosecute
Clinton for what were obvious felony
violations of the Espionage Act
including mishandling top-secret
classified intelligence on that unsecure
private server at a mom-and-pop shop
bathroom closet they also chose not to
prosecute her over the biggest slam-dunk
obstruction of justice charges when she
deleted acid-washed thousands of
subpoenaed emails with bleep spit and
beat up her phones with a hammer and
ripped out the SIM cards any other
American would have been tried and they
would have been charged with felonies
but not Hillary Clinton that's what they
did is they abuse power and then also in
July of 2016
right after they gave her that free pass
that keeps her in the presidential
election the same exact people then use
Hillary Clinton's bought and paid for
phony Russian dirty dossier to open up
an investigation into the Trump campaign
they used the same unverified garbage Oh
to spy on a trump campaign associate and
they were all warned it was unverified
and that Hillary paid for it and it was
never corroborated or verified and that
steel hated Hillary Clinton by the way a
lot of it's since been debunked those
known lies were used to repeatedly four
separate occasions commit fraud on FISA
courts and literally deny a fellow
American of their constitutional rights
and then they used it later remember the
insurance policy to illegally attempt a
coup again using the Russian lies they
knew they were Russian lies they were
briefed that they were Russian lies to
unseat the president that they didn't
like the candidate they didn't like the
one who had smelly Walmart voters
following him
after a month-long investigation meaning
almost nine months Lisa page James call
me others that even admitted there's no
evidence a trump Russia collusion but
that didn't stop this very same group of
unaccountable unelected bureaucrats from
plotting to remove a duly elected
president from office what's this there
were meetings at the Justice Department
in which it was discussed whether the
vice president and a majority of the
cabinet could be brought together to
remove the President of the United
States under the 25th amendment